[Music]
in these courses
we deconstructed the api product
introduced the api product mindset
reviewed the customer experience with
customer journeys and personas
and now we would like to offer a few
tips on how to formulate your api
product strategy
starting with the design of your api
products
recall the keys to an api product
mindset
approach the design with the consumer in
mind
enable fast time to market with reusable
assets
and don't boil the ocean but rather
iterate to continuously improve the
product
api products are your digital product
line and like any product line
it can target different consumers by
adding small tweaks to the product
you should treat each api as you would
any other product you produce in your
organization
one of the simplest examples of a
product is made by the coca-cola
beverage company
the company originally came out with the
coca-cola soda and over the past
90 years have branched out into fitness
beverages
teas juices and different types of water
each product has its own target audience
for example
a dwala simply orange and minute maid
are beverages targeted at families with
young children
fair life and core power are targeted at
the health conscious and fitness
fanatics
and the coca-cola company also offers a
variety of water beverages including
smart water
vitamin water and zico coconut water
similarly your api product strategy will
have different product offerings for
different target audiences
you may have an api product for general
partners and a different api product for
closely held partners
for example those partners that are
represented with a business associates
agreement with our company
your product strategy will begin to
shape itself organically as your product
line grows
and is important that you focus on your
api consumer needs
consider any digital transaction you
engage in today
using your phone to buy coffee ordering
something online
and then tracking the delivery or even
updates in your bank account
each one of these transactions is an
experience with an api behind it
when you design api products you should
ask questions like
what problems do my api consumers face
how do i make the api product easy to
consume
how might you measure the impact of the
solution you provided them
taking a broader view you might ask
yourself
how do i get started and then a host of
follow-on questions arise
like do i start designing api products
for an internal audience
or jump right into an external audience
can proxies be reused in multiple api
products
are there policies that are standard
across the enterprise that
can be reused in api products
the answers to these questions will form
your api product strategy
and furthermore the strategy must
support your business
with that said as you embark on your api
product strategy
the best way to help guide your design
is to provide you with an example
let's look at the leading ticket sales
and distribution company
their original target audience for apis
were their own internal developers
the company designed the apis around
event discovery and online ticket sales
to enable their developers to bring new
features to market faster
and in the process quickly found other
benefits when they focused on the api
consumer
apis were initially focused on their
internal developers who are creating
applications for their internal call
center
and online website for purchasing
tickets the focus was purely on the
needs of the
internal developer without much
reusability in mind
the top two problems the company faced
was how to secure the connection
and the data for the application and how
to prevent bots from simulating online
purchasers holding tickets
and thus driving up the cost of the
ticket due to artificial demand
in solving for the problems the company
found that the security policies
could be reused by both internal and
partner developers
and so they were able to create api
products reusing the same security
policies for partners
such as costco who included the ability
to search for events and purchase
tickets on their website
the company found that they could create
api products for each trusted partner
while reusing the same security policies
and demand
for their api products amongst partners
grew
due to the high demand the company found
that they could engage additional
third-party supply
to help meet the demand demand continued
to grow with iot
devices coming into the picture
consumers wanted to search for events
and order tickets
via voice-activated devices such as the
google home assistant
and thus an api product ecosystem was
born with demand and supply running
through the api product ecosystem
powered by the google apigee platform
the company grew from a limited supply
delivered through a closed private
channel to a vibrant marketplace with an
ecosystem of api products with
third-party suppliers
to be consumed by new marketing channels
creating services that the company
didn't need to build
the added benefit was that the new
services cost little to the company to
provide
there is no one approach to designing
your api product strategy
rather there is an approach that you can
take to define an initial api product
design
and refine it over time your api product
strategy
will mature organically it's important
that you don't boil the ocean to begin
your journey
use customer journeys and personas to
design api products that have a notable
business impact and
iterate from there along your journey
you will find repeatable patterns such
as the security rules mandated by your
corporate security office
that you will want to build out as
standard policies for reuse
it's always a good idea to design your
product for external consumers
even if your initial audience is
internal
finally review actual usage of your api
products
and refine them based on your metrics
and user feedback to continuously
improve your product
like your api products your product
strategy
will evolve over time hopefully you've
found a few strategies in this video to
define your api product strategy
thank you for watching
you